[Música]
oi meu nome é sofia eu tenho 11 anos
estão a 5º ano
hoje irei falar sobre como a internet
influencia na vida na vida das pessoas e
os cyber bullying cyber bullying o tema
também chamada de assédio virtual é um
normalmente é praticado por redes
sociais como o instagram sinepe tchetcha
facebook twitter entre outras
envolve uso das tecnologias de
informação e comunicação para dar apoio
e comportamentos liberadas repetido seu
xixi e normalmente são praticadas por um
por um indivíduo ou grupo comparar os
cyber during nessa slide mostra seis
dicas de como como evitá lo primeiro
procure por sinais de abuso segundo
procure por sinal de humilhação pública
terceiro sabe as evidências quarto
tente identificar a causa quinto para
responder às mensagens do agressor e
sexto
não espere muito para pedir ajuda e um
que não está escrito é um bloqueio mais
rápido possível agressor
essa história de júlia gabrielli chega
abre é lhe estudante de 12 anos vítima
de cyber boni promovido por algumas
páginas de amor do facebook elas
postaram fotos da garota e fizeram
brincadeiras desagradáveis sobre os seus
pêlos faciais e a foto ao lado mostra um
twitter
há algumas coisas que ela postou a
primeira é me chama de gabrielle e
queria que vocês pararem de fazer essa
maldade comigo nunca fiz nada contra
vocês por favor verdade e mentira
muitas pessoas acham que estão
protegidas por está atrás de telas de
computador e por isso podem praticar o
cyber bullying sem arcar com as
consequências mas na verdade ela
erradas a primeira foto é mostra quatro
mulheres olhando fixamente para o
celular
talvez percebendo as outras ao seu lado
mas não se interessam muito e ao lado
mostra três mulheres conversando e se
divertido sem sem o celular na mão
a influência da internet na vida das
pessoas
o problema faz com que as pessoas não
conversam muito cara a cara e conversa
em e conversa em mais por redes sociais
contribuição permite que as pessoas se
comuniquem mais rapidamente com outras
que estão distantes como é
impressionante a rapidez do mundo a
tecnologia tem evoluído de forma
impressionante
com o passar dos anos e uma pesquisa que
durava há um tempão agora pode levar
diminutas as segundas relacionamento
familiar
a internet aproxima de estâncias pessoas
exemplo filho desligar o fogo da panela
de pressão por favor
espera aí mãe tô mandando uma mensagem
da aline vai rápido senão feijão queima
eu estou esperando eu tinha me atender o
skype e já vou avisando
nada de usar o celular durante almoço tá
muito menos na hora de dormir
esse tipo de conversa evidencia uma
verdade sem dúvida a internet vem
interferindo de forma como nos
relacionamos mudanças e aqui não falamos
somente o surgimento de abreviações e
novas gírias
por exemplo você brinca falou entre
outras se a data de uma matéria sobre a
internet mas analisamos principalmente a
forma como as relações em família têm
sido afetadas
essa é uma história contada pelo
motorista tenha mesa e não no espírito
santo ajuda em melbourne austrália ela
viu uma mulher olhando fixamente para
celular
olhando ao lado todos estavam com o
celular na mão para tirar fotos daquele
lugar lindo que talvez até no mar mas
quando ela foi ela é mais de perto
na verdade ela estava olhando seu filho
no facebook como ela estava olhando
fixamente para o celular e não percebeu
o fim
e acabou caindo no mar muitas crianças
aqui na escola não tem os pais por perto
o dia inteiro porque eles trabalham
muito mas ele normalmente ficam coladas
no celular
e é nesse slide mostra quatro ideias do
que fazer
podem fazer colagens desenhos ver filmes
e ler que muitas crianças não fazem
tomara que vocês tenham gostado obrigada